[Musique]
à
pour établir des prévisions
météorologiques sur terre il faut une
vue de l'espace
et pour obtenir ce point de vue spatial
il faut une fusée lancée en novembre
dernier la mise en orbite de capteurs
ultra précis marque le début d'une
nouvelle génération de satellites
météorologiques
[Musique]
ce lancement annonce l'avènement d'une
nouvelle ère celle de la prévision
numérique
porté par les superordinateurs
au coeur de ce déploiement se trouve une
pièce cruciale
conçu au québec son nom l'interféromètre
un instrument de détection est
essentielle aux prévisions
métérologiques l'instrument mesure celui
pensée conçue et réalisée par
l'entreprise abb est un sondeur
infrarouge bardé de 1300 capteurs il
offre un niveau de résolution 100 fois
plus élevés que par le passé au total
l'interféromètre recueil et retourne à
la terre 45000 donné à la seconde assez
de pixels par représenter des profils de
température et des niveaux d'humidité du
sol jusqu'à l'atmosphère et ce en trois
dimensions il fournit tant
d'informations que seul un
superordinateur peu les digérer
au delà de la température et d'humidité
atmosphérique
le satellite permet aussi de tenir la
couverture de glace de la mer la
trajectoire d'un ouragan et même
l'étendue géographique d'une panne
électrique
finalement en améliorera les prévisions
météorologiques à court terme celle qui
justement vous font si souvent rage et
le japon lancera d'ici quelques mois
le deuxième satellite à bord duquel
retrouvera la technologie québécoise un
satellite sera ensuite déployé tous les
cinq ans fini les prévisions erronées
vive la précision
[Musique]